hello I am so excited this is such a
treat so I feel like I never get to talk
to you about rocking oh yeah yeah that's
true most of the if I ever signed stuff
it's usually rocket is that the role you
gotta approach about the most oh yeah by
far how did you find the voice like I
always am like that's Bradley Cooper and
I'm trying to find it yeah I mean we
just uh I just created it with James we
worked on it I had like a bunch of ideas
and we sort of landed you know it was
fun it was It was kind of crazy the the
that process but once we landed on him
it felt right and then and then it just
then it was like it was like sort of
that was it we were Off to the Races and
James always talks about how Rockets his
favorite character rocket is really the
main character of the Guardians Trilogy
so what can you tease about this movie
which seems like I'm going to be in a
puddle of Tears well you know he did
talk to me about that initially too that
he felt he had this sort of end game for
rocket and US learning about his origin
and you never know if that's actually
going to happen yeah and then lo and
behold we get to this third script and I
read it I'm like oh my gosh that's
exactly what he talked about and um it
was the emotional is the right word you
know I watched a cut of it a while ago
and I cried pretty hard just why I mean
I I yeah I mean it's pretty hardcore a
little rocket he went through a lot dude
he went through a lot yeah oh I just
want to help him that's the least of it
great awesome hey can't wait yeah um is
this has been described as one last ride
so is this your final time playing
Rocket Raccoon do you think I go
wherever James tells me
if your eye on any
of that series he did I thought that was
incredible like blew me away and I just
think he's uh you know as I said I'm
just glad he's working making movies in
television I'm trying to learn The
Peacemaker opening sequence the dance
yes so I mean it's incredible isn't that
it shows did you watch the whole thing
yes it's unbelievable unbelievable John
Cena is incredible not a vigilante
character oh dude it's insane yeah yeah
that shows nuts I couldn't believe it
yeah I'd love to see you over there yeah
over there yeah we got to see that we
gotta see this beautiful face
in front of the camera yeah
I love it so you said people come up to
you the most and talk about rocket we're
gonna talk about rocket
where does Rocket rank for you out of
all the characters you've played you've
stayed with that character for a while I
don't know but I love them that's got to
be something special for something you
embody for so long that's the thing is
to be able to like have him evolve and
yeah it's nuts and and to play him you
know because I record it all after they
shoot it and I did I mean I've been in
various places around the world and I
think back like we've James and I have
worked together in so many crazy
locations yeah yeah it's been really
kind of amazing yeah that's amazing
Bradley thank you so much
foreign
[Music]